- Illuminati Planet Hulk Avengers 3 star
Emily VanCamp is your new Miss America
how do you feel about that in case you
don't watch revenge she does action
pretty well it's almost like a
superheroes dress you know like you
could fight crime in that tie I like to
fight a bit of crime in the new Captain
America movie the Winter Soldier it's
likely that the character will still be
a part of shield we do know however that
she will have a romantic relationship
with Chris Evans character you think yes
Superbowl news Beyonce Destiny's Child
black out Ravens murder Bowl so let's
there to say about the Hulk spoilers
although it hasn't been confirmed it
looks like at the end of Avengers 2
there will be a scene either in the post
credits or at the end of the movie where
a movie version of the Illuminati shoot
Hulk deep into space setting the stage
for drumroll please Planet Hulk this is
all part of late phase 2 phase 3 Marvel
movies phase 3 we give Mark Ruffalo of
his own solo movie for more Planet Hulk
details check out the description below
Planet Hulk ends up becoming a movie
that means that Avengers 3 would set the
stage for the return of the Hulk to seek
revenge on the Illuminati who shot him
into space this would also open the door
for the character Skaar who in the comic
books is Holt's son so big Captain
America 2 news Planet Hulk Illuminati
Avengers 3 yes hey thanks for watching
be sure to subscribe and like the video
below and watch my community season 4
video